en l'honneur de la grâce beauté
le charme et le poison de la femme brésilienne
tropical
Je vis
dans un pays tropical
Béni par Dieu
il y a carnaval dans carnaval il y a des oeufs que le
guitare je suis Flamengo j'ai un démenti
appelée Thérèse
Je vis
dans un pays tropical
Béni par Dieu
par nature
il y a du carnaval dans le carnaval
Je suis Flamengo, j'ai un appel négatif
Thérèse
Je ne suis peut-être pas un baiser de Dieu parce que c'est
mais à la maison tous mes amis à moi
les petits camarades me respectent car c'est
est la raison de la sympathie du Pouvoir de quelque chose
plus et joie
où je vis
dans un pays tropical
Béni par Dieu
et belle par nature à recevoir
il y a carnaval
Carnaval
Je suis Flamengo, j'ai un rappel
Teresa, je suis Flamengo
dans un patropi
béni
Beau
quelle beauté en février
en février il y a du karma oui
personne n'a vu je suis planète
de Flamengo il y a une fille qui s'appelle Teresa
Flamengo a une fille nommée Terezinha
Je suis Flamengo et je ne traite personne
mais pas toujours brésilien
Flamengo a une fille qui s'appelle Tereza